Hi.
I'm Mano Marks with the Maps
Developer Relations team here
at Google in Mountain View.
I am going to talk to you today
about the Google Maps
SDK for iOS and specifically
about some new marker
management features that
we added to the
SDK in version 1.2.
So in version 1.1, when you had
a map, when you wanted to
add a marker you added the
marker from the map object.
Let's take a look at what that
code actually looks like.
You can see here in older
versions, 1.1 and before, you
would create a GMSMarkerOptions
object and
create a CLLocationCoordinate
object.
And then with MapView,
you would call
addMarkerWithOptions and give
it the options object.
We don't do that anymore.
The reason that we don't do
that anymore is because we
wanted to give you a lot more
control over marker objects.
Let's take a look at what
code looks like today.
So you can see here, I've got
two arrays, two immutable
arrays, and what I'm doing is
I'm just adding random markers
into those arrays.
And you'll see what I'm doing
is I'm creating the marker
object, GMSMarker object,
separate from the map.
What this allows you to do is
then assign the marker to any
map object that you want to
use in your application.
It also allows you to do
interesting things, like
create your own marker
management tools and
techniques, you can create
your own quadtrees or
clustering algorithms, or
anything that you want, which
wasn't previously easy to do
with the Google Maps SDK.
So you see here, each
marker that--
I'm adding 10 markers--
and every other marker I'm
adding making it green.
And you'll see here, we also
added to this add marker.
You could add colors to your
marker using the marker image
with color.
And so what that looks like here
is you see I have red and
green markers being
added to the map.
And this allows me to do things
like walk through one
or the other of the arrays and
just turn on or off each
marker by simply assigning
the map to nil.
So when you want to assign a
marker to a map, you just say
marker.map equals this
particular map view.
Or you assign it to nil.
The marker objects still exists,
it's still something
that's around for you to use,
and you can assign it back to
the map when you want to.
So you'll see here,
that allows us to
do things like this.
I've got this simple one here.
Here, I can turn off all the
markers by simply assigning
them map.nil.
I can turn on all the red or I
could turn on all the green,
because they're in
separate arrays.
So pretty simple but powerful
change that gives you a lot
more control over how you manage
markers in the iOS SDK.
So that's it.
That's your shortcut
for today.
Thanks for tuning in, and
we'll see you next week.